did you watch the oprah interview with
uh megan and harry have you watched any
clips from it i watched clips
i started to do the whole thing and i
realized oh i don't give a [ __ ] about
half of this
so yeah i just wanted to get to the
dirty stuff you know yeah
the real juicy stuff yeah well uh
like my wife is obsessed and
and i didn't even know that she was
obsessed and she didn't even know that
she was obsessed
she's going online reading british
papers
this morning i caught her reading the
telegraph to find out
what people and i thought what are you
reading their telegraph for we don't
even live in
england yeah but no everyone's lost
their mind over this
it's a huge huge story
this oprah interview with harry and
megan well last night
it finally aired in the uk and of course
the ratings were huge
everyone in britain wanted to see it but
this was odd this was i thought a very
odd choice cbs
the network airing the interview they
decided to
re-air all the same advertisements that
they had aired here in america
but they adjusted the ads slightly
for british audiences i thought that was
strange
take a look more of my interview with
megan and harry
when we come back you can buy a little
bit of everything at kohl's
at affordable prices coals it's like
harrods for poor people oi
and you yanks think all food is [ __ ]
applebees ancestry.com for the british
royal family
find out which second cousin you're
accidentally dating
oreo biscuits there's a black and white
marriage we can all agree on
i thought the oreo ad was unnecessary
that was
they didn't need to do that no no we all
know what an oreo is